A lot of times,
when I choreograph,
I had to look
at the environment
and that kind of sparks,
you know, what
we're going to do in there.
The ramen stand
that she's eating
in the beginning,
I mean, that thing
wasn't designed to...
we never thought
someone's gonna fall,
like clip at the top of it
and fall down to the ground.
So, we thought about it
and go, oh wow,
we can maybe
have the gangsters
try to come from all levels,
top floor, bottom floor,
so just to make it busy.
I just wanted
to make it multi-level.
So, we actually
had a stunt guy,
she shoots him,
he falls out the window,
rolls from the other roof
onto the top of the stand
and then onto the ground.
So, we had to reinforce it,
move the stand closer,
so I know
it's physically possible
to clip it.
And so, it always hurts,
but you know,
so they don't really
get seriously injured.
All right, so that's one.
A lot of another thing too
was we have Mary running
up to the second floor
and we made the path
go to second floor.
Then I'm like, okay,
she's not going to go back
to the first floor,
she's going to...
we had to run down
this side of the roof
and we had to kinda
build that
where she could run
on top of it
and it's structural,
all right.
And at the same time,
because she's running
at a height,
we had to figure out, okay,
we've gotta put
a wire system
and a wire assist,
so she can kinda jump
from one rooftop
to the other.
It's just interesting
to see those.
Like once you get
in the environment,
just a lot of the stuff
just changes
and just gets bigger.
When she runs
into the bathhouse,
we entered a bathhouse
in Thailand
and the actual bathhouse
was in Japan, right.
And then when she runs out,
she's back in Thailand,
I think what was interesting
about that piece is
once she goes
into the bathhouse,
that's real Japan.
There's a rhythm
when you do the action
because I think if you make
everything at 100%
all the way through,
people get
desensitised to it.
So, you want to make
peaks and valleys
in terms of emotional arcs
or rhythm when you do
these fight scenes.
So, you want to start off
with tension
and then it goes fast
and then
there's a moment of levity.
Got to find that.
It's almost
like physical language.
Call it physical language.
So, it's a scene,
but everything's done
physically.
So, you still
have to have those peaks
and arcs of emotion
throughout the fight.
Otherwise, it's just
a big blur of movement
and I think people
tend to need
a little moment of levity
where everything slows down
so they can ingest it.
She's doing
super-long takes.
So, she's running
up and down,
running up these stairs
doing all these things,
so it's just a multitude
of things she had to do.
And it's really hot
over there,
so at night it's humid,
it's really hot,
they're all wearing
long sleeved shirts
and pants
and things like that,
but she's just doing
long takes
and she's doing everything.
So, I can't really say
what one thing
is harder than the other.
I just think
it's just compounding
all that stuff onto her.
It's a lot. But she does it.